you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that I recently observed
online live this was a three minute
blitz game played on HS org on the white
end seven-year-old prodigy T own Chernov
from Ukraine who goes by the handle
Pesce CH on Leach s his opponent feed a
master Edouard Miller from Germany who
goes by the handle fluffy so let's dive
into this one and see what happened or
really exactly what happened towards the
end of this game the game opens with e4
we have a Sicilian defense open Sicilian
and the variation and dragon often
leading to sharp play this game is no
exception in fact it's over by move 23
Bishop III follows there is no fear at
this moment of Knight to g4 as Bishop to
b5 would be the reply and black would
have to interfere with the protection of
the knight or drop into c6 and that
wouldn't be good either so continuing
Bishop to g7 at this moment it's
important to first secure the bishop
before playing Queen to d2 why am i
drawing some attention to this well
because there was a bit of a move order
issue in this game Queen to d2 was
played before f3 this now allows black
to play Knight to g4 but you know this
is blitz and they're blitzing out the
moves black doesn't capitalize on this
slight move order issue instead playing
a6 so now we have f3 and continuing
getting some more development in
queenside castle and here comes this
mini pawn race each side expanding on
opposite wings b5h for Bishop b7 and now
white secures the knight on c3 Queen c7
other moves at this point include rook
c8
or trying to kind of put a halt to this
expansion on the kingside with h v clean
c7 in the game and G for so this is
really looking to push through with H
five nine to b6 this is a weak point the
weakest point in White's camp c4 and
it's important to you know keep this
Bishop around to watch over this point
and this is why in these positions where
you have a queenside castle and you
start launching the h on the jeep on
this is why you don't really make a
bishop move he just kind of kind of
wants to sit there in his home square
and be prepared to knock out a knight in
one stroke if he hops into the c-4
square so you're not wasting any Tempe
so continuing we have h5 just swinging
the back completely around h5 it is and
surprisingly enough it already is a bit
uncomfortable for Team Black why do I
say this
well the next move rook to g8 is
certainly awkward but it is best what's
the issue with let's say queenside
castling here you know just connecting
rooks the issue is that you can
sacrifice on b5
and after a recapture night takes b5
what would black do here
currently the Queen would be under fire
the night is under fire and how do you
move the Queen and still successfully
defend the night on b6
you can playing to c6 would run into a
fork so this is the big issue you just
can't do this natural looking you know
let's complete development queenside
castle and so rook to g8 is at least
preparing to you know now that you
cannot connect rooks you better just
concede in this h-file to team white
and should this be the idea to play aged
six the bishop could of course back up
but with all of these Tempe white is not
looking forward to simply closing the H
file the idea is to open that side with
the board and well this is what we have
h takes g 6h takes and now g5 just
pressing forward oftentimes you'll see
this little tucking in type of move but
this is far more direct play night after
d7 follows so currently there's one
night eyeing c4 and not long enough
there can be a second and things can
really turn in a blink a night on c4 is
just super invasive
so what I found interesting about this
game was well looking at the stats you
know after the game was over with I
thought you know that it felt as I was
watching it it felt like it was really
strong and sure enough play from here
were at move 15 the play by white was
impeccable from this point top moves in
every case and again this is just a
3-minute game
and well just a seven-year-old at the
board so Luke age seven is the next move
right now he's you know putting pressure
on the bishop let's see what black does
sure enough Knight to e5 and this is
where T own thought for about 40 seconds
and I found I found myself as I was
watching you know what would I have done
in this position and I didn't I didn't
quite come up with the move that white
played here so I'll actually throw the
you know throw a pop quiz your way what
move would you play here as white feel
free to pause the video okay well yeah
again as I was watching I found myself a
little bit behind it was only after I
saw the move did I realize oh that's the
point well 40 seconds of thought
produced a perfect move Queen to h4 okay
this is you really can't prevent the
knight from getting into this square
it's I mean if you try to do b3 this is
just way to weakening you know the C 3
square is collapsing you may even see
you know H are the a pond being targeted
at some stage
he has a much more direct approach light
at this stage Queen to h2
you know the knight could jump in but
now there's a great cost you see that
you see the threat connected with Queen
to h2 White's ready to take the bishop
and after a recapture sweep into h8 and
pick off the unprotected rook on g7
sharp play what is black do well black
has to make another uncomfortable move
but one of the one of the best moves if
not the best move in this position King
to f8 once more you cannot queenside
castle because of these sacrifices on b5
same story in this position as well so
King to f8 in the game and at this point
I think I do best to show you exactly
how this game finished and with of
course you know I could only do this
with having first received permission
but I think I do best to simply share
Tian's perspective from this point on ok
wait wall what can it wait
of all
and no Castle castle this here and no
castle
yes here Gyo which three
oh and my position better sinks
lady since we're threat or visually 7r
almost finish it girls days in which to
New York
oh my idea 96 nice check ol time
take troubling opened
oh my position listen Queenie
Oh
he takes chop and this hand in this hand
this hand and queen of sea 5000 who does
check this very epic made yeah Irene
since we can feed the master fluffy not
only was this a very epic name but this
was just a really well played game I
mean it's a three minute game and just
finding a way to seize the initiative
was very instructive to me and I mean if
you're curious at all about how well
played this game is let's have a look at
the tale the tape inaccuracies mistakes
and blunders just a zipping through here
average sent upon loss 23:14 white and
66-14 black out of a Sicilian dragon
really well played game to say the least
and I've sent it before in a previous
video T own I mean it's really great to
see such a young talent at the game and
you certainly have a big fan in me so
continue to grow buddy and as usual feel
free those of you here watching feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below
and well I hope you enjoyed it that's
all for now take care bye
you